valérie bénaïm si autoproclamé la reine
de la loge maquillage et personne n'ose
lui faire face elle est prioritaire sur
la maquilleuse et la coiffeuse qui
doivent automatiquement laisser de côté
les autres chroniqueurs rambades d'accès
par toi source l'équipe tpm paix mais
surtout gilles verdez
c'est un secret bien gardé mais là j'en
ai marre nerfs je vais vous expliquer
moi un refi taux voudrait me faire
maquiller normalement et on me dit cette
place est réservée pour benhaim étant
que benhaim n'a pas sa maquilleuse
valérie c'est pas vrai ou pas ben muna
tant que vous n'êtes étant passée on
vous réserve une place comme vous êtes
en retard j'attends une heure
non mais quand vous êtes un chouchou
bien cyrille personne n'ose vous le dire
moi je le dis de la part de tout le
monde on en a ras-le-bol de vovinam
bientôt quelle adorable à l'antenne mais
c'est vrai qu'il est assez odieux ray
n'est pas aimable et j'en sais beaucoup
de médailles mais pas du tout parce que
j'arrive sur la première donc il n'y a
personne
donc je vais là où il ya une pelade il
déplace à fouiller par ibou pas fouiller
pour bafouer gilles et isabelle se rend
deux soirées people uniquement pour
boire et manger gratuitement avec leur
conjoint
source technicien anonyme entendu
discuter au sujet d'un concours de miss
oh la la c'est dégueulasse mais c'est
vrai
c'est vrai pour lui c'est pas vrai pour
moi tu es là aussi agiter l'asie
m'accompagnant nous attendent ma
campagne aussi tu peux pas m'arrêter
teradyne dans mon dos reis et puis
surtout il ya eu même source guillaume
genton à aulas voit la robe que gilles
n'a aucun respect pour autrui il m'a
appelé antoine pendant six mois
jean m'appelle par mon vrai prénom
depuis peu c'est vrai mais pendant des
mois je crois pendant six mois il
m'appelait antoine c'est vrai cyril
parfois quand je vais vous interpellé
des gens ton parce que j'ai peur de
faire une erreur de prénom en fait vous
êtes transparent pour moi
c'est sympa émissions moyennes vraiment
il
doit vraiment c'est la cohue
j'adore la cohésion humaine géraldine
maillet en faire une très belle
bouteille à benjamin castaldi lors son
anniversaire à la passagère il lui a dit
qu'il s'était régalé alors qu'en réalité
ne l'a jamais vu car elle traîne encore
en loge de tout chez moi
une chroniqueuse meurtri chat le
dimanche 28 mars 2021 c'est
l'anniversaire de benjamin castaldi il
n'y a pas de tpm dès ce jour là donc dès
le lundi j'arrive avec un paquet cadeau
et avec une bouteille magnifique de
prosecco je lui offre il est ravi il me
remercie et le lendemain il dit je me
suis régalé je les vis avec ma femme
merci oui hier je vais dans les loges je
cherche une veste j'ouvre le casier de
benjamin castaldi et je découvre le
paquet cadeau
c'est vrai mais ça me rappelle un
certain cyril lma qui y en a maintenant
connu
c'était dans la sauce
celui-là me mettre dans la sauce il est
fou ce mec-là écoute moi bien castaldi
était nul c'est horrible ce que tu as
fait mal il fera prosecco c'est un vin à
7h ouais c'est l'argent qui compte vous
avez un droit d'asile ne s'envenime à
chérir y connais rien au procès comme
dans les contes antoine et et crevettes
de madagascar
[Applaudissements]
pour ses cours à 42 euros le kilo tu
m'appelleras ma fille
y aller petit prix et les grands groupes
y avait une très belle bouteille pour
maintenant elle est par ailleurs dieu
pourquoi toi benjamins du coup j'ai
récupéré la bouteille non non non je
vais l'offrir à cathy qui s'occupe de
nous
[Applaudissements]
à
l'essieu jane pompiers qui vient
d'arriver sur l'émission de tout de
suite elle qui m'écrit a apparemment
guillaume genton elle me dit il m'a
demandé de le choisir oh là là pendant
la pub m'envoyer un sms
je souhaite m'en moque vérifiez donc je
sois j benjamin l'honnêteté c'est
important voilà qui m'écrit ça à
l'instant
c'est ça c'est ça moi c'est son numéro
et
tu nous prends pour des culs terreux
c'est
bien cette petite quand même encore
vachement on est alors là à 6,6 à fin
mai c'est ça qui lui a permis de fin de
de perdre autant d'argent
c'est pour ça
sur ce match de l'en but ouais samedi
soir à deauville benjamin a fini
complètement ivre et ingérable l'ordure
soirée pourtant distingué classe alors
alors alors qu'elle s'en soit pas du
tout voilà je devrais me suis quelqu'un
d'autre qui je vais voter
je vais raconter toute la soirée mais ce
que tu étais présent mathieu il a vécu
n'était pas seul d'ailleurs cette soirée
alors est ce que tu t'étais c'était mon
truc
je vous dis une chose on a passé un
excellent animée avec la faute d'avoir
les bras
effectivement on n'a pas une mesure et
qui c'est qui s'est rallongée dans la
soirée voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on a on
a vu beaucoup de moscow news alors et
j'étais pas ingérable était de très
bonne humeur très bonne humeur nous
avons doit savoir de diyala votre
carrière que toi qui veut ça quand même
bah ouais j'ai dîné avec elle définit un
peu fatigués ça
je dois le confesser elle cela un crime
à consommer avec modération bien
évidemment ça sur mes pas conduit après
non
le problème c'est quand il pourrait
parfois ils se trompent de deux foyers
de ce qu'il a coûté ses quatre mariages
voilà donc alors donc non ça va il est
rattrapé et titubait gains peuvent au
mieux tous
les gens dans l'élégant et toujours
du monde non mais t'as pas reconnus
à voyager sur vous mathieu fixe les gens
dans la rue en espérant qu'ils le
reconnaissent eux lui demande des self
et source audio genton alors en fait un
jeu je suis allé boire un café sur les
champs-elysées ouais et pendant une
heure j'ai assisté un triste spectacle
ouais le vil matthieu delormeau en train
de faire des allers-retours sur les
champs contre les gens le reconnaissent
il journée celle ci n'ont fait cette
fois l'aller-retour sur les champs en
mer bayh avait deux trois photos mais
c'était pas ou ne l'est plus bon tu vas
faire pour devrait donc non c'est ici
qu'est ce que tu veux les allers retours
sur les champs ces parades que je fais
de temps en temps et c'est assez remet
de temps en temps j'ai eu des petites
test de popularité
voilà je regarde à tout petit peu
effectivement quand je marche sur une
avenue combien de personnes vont
m'arrêter pour me parler quand je vois
ça descend un petit peu je mange de
nombre d'émissions et voilà c'est parce
que j'avais des gens et je pense qu'il
m'aime aussi que de total vous l'avez
jamais fait vous savez jamais vous
balader sur une avenue en croisant les
gens pour voir combien on faire de
photos par mail et vous êtes-vous jamais
alors ils t'appellent
jour des jardins publics
je le reconnais
sinon c'est pas non plus voilà c'est pas
la folie il ya non alors et alors vous
avez des solutions d'avaya pas ultime tu
m'avais genre ouais mais pas eu de trois
photos nous trouver au moins 7 ah oui on
sait c'est qu'elle aille moins 7 et j'ai
fait concorde
ce golf c'est encore de la chanter
l'hymne cette fois
en une journée c'est pas dingue après sa
décharge c'était peut-être plein de
touristes dans les bons
je ne pense pas que ça ne pense pas et
chérie extend nouvelle les nouvelles
peaux qui montiel a pris un melon
incroyable il a déclaré cette semaine
j'ai quand même de la chance d'avoir eu
autant de succès d'audience aucune
émission présentée par mois n'a connu de
byd source de gilbert bécaud et
absolument
[Rires]
pas ces deux horloges et la mer à [ __ ]
de sa ville et l'a10 récits merveilleux
alors si ab j'aurais rien dit si c'était
pas pointé contre vous parce qu'il dit
quand je pense qu'à nous n'a lui a eu
des ratés moi jamais etc mais ça il faut
que les gens parce qu'on me dit dans les
sondages en même bien montiel mais mon
tienne c'est une rature
non justement justement justement d'un
vous vous faites bien parce que à merci
j'ai un deuxième volet aaa à bernard
montiel et je vais vous dire j'ai
découvert
le côté obscur de bernard montiel
face cachée de montiel de mai longtemps
oui montiel
vous êtes un menteur
s'ils n'ont pas mieux de toman oui un
comédien ça oui une sombre merde
c'est d'aimer
montiel
j'aurais convoi la séquence d'hier où il
apprend qu'il est le deuxième animateur
préféré des gens de ses 8 1 hier il a
fait genre qu'il était très étonné oui
voilà il a dit 'très bonne et je ne
savais même pas qu'il y avait son âge
c'est vrai c'est vrai sauf qu'on a une
capture d'écran sur twitter il a dit je
n'étais pas au courant mais la veille il
avait leaké ce classement mais non alors
qu'on en a parlé dans l'émission est
regardée regardez regardez il y a un
jour bravo les garçons bernard montiel a
leaké
alalala bernard montiel est ici c'était
un jour avant non non mon team alors
c'est que ça c'est possible parce que je
like facilement à ses personnels a dû
voter à mortier
qui pensent qu montiel a menti
qui pensent que montiel a voté toute la
nuit
non bernard montiel ça faisait mon nom
on vous aime bernard montiel mais vous
savez comme matthieu delormeau et plutôt
la vérité
bernard vous étiez au courant de ce
classement vous l'avez laïque et à
l'oral heureusement maïs est marrant oui
mais c'est mort parce que j'ai pas fait
attention valérie bénaïm s'il vous plaît
non je croise les doigts
valérie il est passé par là dessus on
arrête mais j'aurais là et que n'importe
quoi sans regarder 200 terrils
débile
tu sais quoi je n'ai même pas lu alors
tu vois c'est marquer mais c'est annick
rodrigues parce que je le vois nous
avait
demandé à celle en qui j'ai le plus
confiance ici des images
mathieu chéri le crois qu sûr je crois
pas d'autant plus que deux trois jours
avant j'avais eu au téléphone et il me
disait au téléphone je comprends c'est
un peu compliqué je peux pas accepter
plus d'émissions j'ai déjà énormément de
prime sur ces 8 il disait je suis
l'animateur phare si ces prix homme et
comme sera excellent galles sur un prime
bernard parce que je vous aime
énormément vous le savez quand même bah
comme rodriguez baladerait série voilà
donc vous aurez apprennent bientôt ça
vous fait plaisir mais bien sûr nous
sommes peu plus les vidéos cage mais on
pouvait reconnaître quand même que j'ai
jamais rien ne te réclames et non mais
je réclame et orange coup droit
source bureau
quand il anime le 6 à 7 bernard montiel
réussi la performance de faire moins
d'audience que la publicité dans la même
émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai et c'est prêt c'est la
vraie celle après c'est vrai qu'il ya
une pub william saurin qui a très bien
marché sur la lune on se régalait quoi
c'est alors voilà ça c'est mon cas donc
je gagne je dors à la sas et la pub
voilà exactement et donc la pub fait
plus qu'avant les gens aiment plus
l'univers de william saurin que de
guerre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est leur écoute j'ai commandé une
étude non c'est une vrai combat c'était
vrai comptes détaillés quoi ça rigolait
vous le croyez vous à la rubrique c'est
une vraie course c'était un jour à ce
arrivé une fois c'est déjà arrivé une
fois c'est arrivé une fois je ne dis pas
ça ça me déprime et servait des mille
fois la pub a fait un peu plus que vous
c'est pas vraiment ça c'est pas possible
ça va pas non plus bon sinon n'en sais
rien du tout il sort étant le deuxième
helvète ont préféré de ces huit dans la
gueule et troisième
[Rires]
une
jeune futur mariage
je te dis quoi
matthieu delormeau vol si li dan dah
c'est bizarre ce gilbert d'être sexy
fait je suis obligé en fait j'aurais
rien dit parce que ça dure depuis des
mois des années j'aurais rien dit mais à
partir du moment où on vole en loge ici
on vous vole vous et ça je ne le tolère
pas alors je vais vous expliquer larnack
à la fin de chaque émission way matthieu
delormeau ils se précipitent là ou bien
avant vous il reste jamais voir les gens
ils aiment pas les gens
il va en loge et en loge vous nous
fournissez un peu d'alimentation dégâts
jusque là où devrait rien
et donc il va dans la loge et hippiques
tout ce qui reste non il le met sous sa
veste il va en logis le cache dans un
sac et il part avec et quand il y avait
son associé qui venaient ici parfois
guillaume frisquet les deux parties
c'est lui brigue au sein et en fait
quand y'a rien il gueule il y a plus
rien à manger il en fait tout ça il le
met à l'accueil le lendemain de sa
propre société de produits halal
nourdine landes il me dit non non il me
dit que c'est vrai oui bien sûr que
c'est vrai vous dites la vérité c'est
grave ça
c'est très grave c'est vrai
c'est vrai
alors c'est pas faux c'est pas faux pas
pas tous les jours
si vous venez voir
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir à mes équipes et des
chips des machins des trucs pour ça ça
va être ça va être perdu dans cet
automne ont regardé la boîte est le
remède lendemain a perdu maintenant ils
assez rigolo persie c'est la wii pas
perdus du tout du tout irait bien dans
duke alors alors mais alors merci pour
mes équipes série vous conseille des
sacs est pas facile mais ça me non mais
c'est des chiots garde des chiens des
biens quand même votre origine remontant
les chiffres des bananes des coca
ça va chercher une petite foule
diarra va justement il ya une peau qui
de vous a à a et à certains chroniqueurs
cas les initiales mdi
mireille dumas isabelle morini bosc lors
des pushs confiant
mais recule par ces maps des prêts de
relancer l'économie
là encore le rêve est exposé aux grands
bisous c'était très mal rigolé
je te préviens les mecs alors benjamin
castaldi fr le blouson du nahd 1
artistes de grande renommée à cyril oui
alors non mais hors antenne cyril a
déclaré que la veste était super il ou
non pas brighi cd qui n'ont pas vécu
jamais dit non quand vous arrivez syrie
de respecter a retiré des eaux et les
aînés et les cadeaux qu'on lui fait si
vous avez une vidéo de
la vidéo
horrible horrible cette heure
c'est horrible
[Applaudissements]
la veille la veste l'alaska fait
l'artiste mais j'aime pas la best on
lève elle-même la veste on dit à la
matière est beaucoup trop claire bas
mais le truc la sandale je vais la coupe
et la fresque exactement la fresque est
magnifique vraiment je trouve que c'est
un travail exceptionnel
dans un cadre de la la la la fresque est
magnifique c'est la couleur dorée
centimes que j'aime pas c'est sûr de
vous êtes sûr de vous virer
attentes et que des salades 1 quand il
faut quand même le dire
ah bah tiens bernard montiel
distribuer du cash aujourd'hui ce
cynisme requis pour qu'il lui fasse ses
propres courses pendant l'émission
source gilles verdez même ça aussi
[Applaudissements]
non mais tu es mon titre vous disiez
vous dit où vous disiez que c'était une
crevasse mais c'est une crevure mondial
je vous écoutiez la release il voit donc
quelqu'un qui s'occupe de nous en
styliste qui s'appelle valentin qui a un
aura dorkel très belle chemise et lui
dit ouais tâche miteux lâcheté ou donc
valentin lui donne le truc et lui dit
tiens voilà 60 balles tu vas aller
m'acheter la chemise mais il lui donne
l'ordre comme si ce monsieur était à son
service qu'on peut demander à vallière
seniors et ce ne sont pas testés 3 quant
à tf1 suit leur nom mais alors moi qui
le croient
façon de s'exprimer n'est pas la mienne
et c'est dommage oui bernard a revanche
et 60 euros ce à ccc bronze a demandé à
valentin demandé valentin de venir je
vais lui demander à l'ortie pour acheter
une veste heures
c'est vrai
il avait une très belle veste et j'ai
dit bien d'avoir une et me l'acheter
effectivement j'ai gardé l'argent tu
aimerais tu lui demandes et très
gentiment pas du tout pas la façon de
s'exprimer moi justement gentiment des
chômeurs si les chéris c'est maintenant
l'heure de la dernière boucle ah je
resterai un truc chaque semaine il y
aura peut-être une personne qui peut
faire une dernière pousse à vous levez
la main si vous avez une dernière pukki
très intéressantes à faire ou une grosse
pukki ci où vous le dit maintenant vous
voulez les et a touché la mer qui pense
avoir une énorme coup qui devait
l'amener à lever la main ce qu'ils
pensent avoir quelque chose de lourd non
pas sera la dernière pour qui
ce qui je pense moi une poule aux débats
non allez donc gérable
moi j'ai un petit bout qui a picoré
juste avant oui à puy guillaume genton à
delphine en fond d'écran non mais si ces
saillies celui là va sembler du cevu
hawaï et belle histoire moi j'ai l'autre
petit bout qui alors à picorer comme ça
matthieu delormeau a lui-même en fond
d'écran
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]